so we've got Michael fashions entire
spring/summer 2016 collection here
classic East Coast hina preppy style but
with a devilish twist quality is going
to be through the roof fit is going to
be ultra precise and they're going to
have serious cystic sex appeal and that
was hard to find when 2006 New York
designer Michael Bastian founded his
line after gigs at Polo Ralph Lauren and
Bergdorf Goodman in 2007 we named him
one of gqueues best new designers in
America when we into the show what was
your reaction when we saw what Michaels
doing this season you know I have a
similar reaction every time the fact
that you could actually grab that outfit
and walk it off the runway right Street
can I put you on the spot
yeah of all that I want to see your five
favorite pieces from the collection okay
the thing I'm before let's do it number
one I'm 65 J leaf print M 65 that's a
stunner and actually you could put this
on over a black t-shirt in navy pants
all right totally cool with it or you
can put a hoodie under or you could put
a shirt and tie and tuxedo pants because
of the way he styles the rest of his
collection the sky's the limit so this
becomes an incredible investment piece
these are clothes that I can wear like
the office I can wear in a city or I can
wear in the country or you can layer
them up and mix them up and not feel
like you've got on t-shirt and jeans
every day
exactly number two the Michael Bastian
rugby shirt and he's taken a lot of the
bells in the whistles way he's taken
away the rugby buttons he's kept the the
slouchy placket and I love the idea that
you can put this under pinstripe suit or
you can wear with a pair of shorts this
is like the piece that just elevates you
this is the piece that gets the head
turning around you and I like to use
what makes you feel cool is that you're
not gonna button your on B button I'm
not even gonna give you but now it's
coming down here a big story number
three the black and white bangle striped
shirts I would say it's a little bit of
a classic piece but the fact that this
is so hard to find out there in the
world makes it a very special piece
classic that you can't find anywhere
exactly our that's three brown Donegal's
suit brown before Francis something
we're going to be talking about a lot in
the spring so again there's Michael
taking spring fabrics to another level
and giving them some interest in older
texture tunnel elbow patches I love that
that's the kind of thing that makes all
the difference to you when you're on
your 15th wear of a suit here we are not
actually two pieces but I'm going to
consider one I call this as cat-burglar
lot half sip sweatshirt with gun patches
with a pair of beautiful cargo chinos in
black but there's still something a
little bit preppy about a flat totally
the glow of the gun matches you yes we
should also have a look at the Michael
Bastian wing it's on the polos here on
the Zipp neck when you see that you know
it's mr. Bastian Easter Easter basket
Michael come on in please
we called this collection bel-air and it
was because California in LA gets a bad
rap style wise every time I'm there I'm
kind of blown away by how chic these
guys are when I are something that
they've kind of created on their own I
was watching these great movies like the
last mogul about Luke Wasserman and so
obviously that's where the leaf print
came from
yeah the Beverly Hills Hotel wallpaper
which to the scale of that is yes she's
super bright against white super bright
so we we actually designed our own
banana League we had little jokes and
things had like a we have like a little
monkey peeking out aha that way it's
cool right at all mr. more just picked
is five favorite pieces from the
collection I'm gonna put you on the spot
and ask you to pick two okay don't like
picking your children all right one
thing stood I really love is this
sweatshirt indigo dyed heavy pique so
this is gonna fade like a pair of jeans
the more you wear it it's it's a very
subtle bright difference from a regular
sweatshirt but when you put it on you
kind of you feel something a little
different and in 15 years that's gonna
look totally different or new sweater on
that I'm 15 washes second thing okay we
always we privatize as not as okay we
we've kind of become the novelty sweater
guy yeah I have two twin nieces 10 years
old
and one of them drew this and my other
drew a little cupcake and the cupcakes
on woman's sweater and this is called
sunshine hills very cool very Cali funny
red and straight from your niece on a
little knees yeah it's awesome thank you
thanks for making a cameo to maybe shake
ah thank you ma'am
subscribe to the GQ YouTube channel
that's it for today thank you